[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième édition de
ce qu'ils emploient nous avons une
opération qui nous permet d'offrir plus
de 5500 offres d'emploi aux habitants de
saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 120 entreprises sont présentes
dans un secteur d'activité différents
qui représente d'ailleurs à dynamique
économique du territoire des entreprises
d'un secteur de l'automobile une
entreprise dans le secteur de
l'industrie dans le secteur du numérique
ou dans le secteur de la construction
les visiteurs ont deux possibilités
ils n'ont pu s'inscrire avant sur une
plate-forme en détaillant leurs
compétences et ont pu accéder à ces
offres d'emploi des rendez-vous ont été
ainsi organisé au total dans la journée
nous aurons plus de 2500 entretien
programmé à l'avance entre des
entreprises et des candidats au delà de
cette opération qu'on appelle une
opération de job dating l'ensemble des
visiteurs peuvent accéder à l'ensemble
de l'offre de services que l'on déploie
sur saint quentin en yvelines pour aider
nos demandeurs d'emploi nos salariés nos
jeunes à trouver un stage un contrat
d'apprentissage un emploi en intérim ou
en cdd en cdi aujourd'hui nous leur
avons proposé l'ensemble de la palette
d'outils
nous lançons un portail où chaque
habitant qui souhaitent autres humains
non pas pour à venir présenter ses
compétences et accéder aux offres
d'emploi publiées par les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines
ils ont aussi la possibilité de
travailler sur leur cv
ils peuvent également passer des pré
entretiens dans gauche avec des drh qui
ont accepté de jouer le jeu aujourd'hui
est de les aider à travailler cette
phase importante ce qui est l'entretien
de recrutement tout au long de la
journée nous avons aussi des ateliers
des conférences qui explique comment
aujourd'hui les entreprises peuvent
avoir de nouvelles méthodes de
recrutement avec des recrutements
tout s'appuie sur les compétences sur ce
qu'on appelle les soft skills qui est
une approche qui se développe et qui a
montré toute sa toute sa pertinence sur
50 à chaque jour il ya soixante six
mille personnes qui habitent à 50 ans
qui vont travailler qui reviennent les
principaux pôles d'économique de l'île
de france et nous avons parallèlement
autant de personnes 66 mille salariés
qui viennent rejoindre saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est plus domicile travail vous savez
son générateur d'un certain nombre de
nuisances et donc c'est l'objectif qu'on
se fixe de rapprocher l'offre et la
demande d'emploi est de permettre aux
saint quentinois de profiter de cette
plate forme économique qui est 50 ans
niveau
[Musique]